Gamers, are you ready to discover the mysteries of the Druids?
I
shared a tattoo of you.
Wait, what?!
You don't find it, Dusko retweeted it.
What?
I'm not a wizard, I'm a druid!
Please, don't insult me.
I ate the human meat.
And then I ate it twice.
Just like Hal again.
Why is the music so cute here?
Oh!
Was it tasty?
If it weren't, would I have gone back for seconds?
Druids have hoods though.
Not Neo-Druids.
So, yesterday we decided that we would all wear wizard hats.
I mean druid hats.
What are you guys talking about?
Oh, heyo!
Koyu!
Shuki, Shuki, Shuki.
Shuki, shuki, shuko, shuko.
Hold on.
My chair is too far away.
I put on my robe and druid hat.
Yeah.
Are neo-druids just wizards?
How would be?
No.
You're looking very unskeletonized today, Mito-wo, thank you.
That would be pretty crazy if I were skeletonized because I don't think I have bones.
Well, maybe like ectoplasmy.
Bones.
Can't wait to see Hal again perform more morally questionable and outright illegal acts.
Well, guys, we're going to the past.
Wait.
How's that song go?
One step at a time.
To the past.
Nah, well, thank you so much for the...
For the 10 gifts of...
Thank you.
We're back here.
happened last time all i remember is mr blake died so sad hi me though hi hi hi before neo druids before neo druids before it might be a druid with a capital d halag in my ocean mr blake got fireballed
17 years of Minto.
We're going to go unalive, not, not, well, I was going to say unalive a baby.
Unbirth a, well, baby, the babies, okay, wait.
The babies are birthed, but do we kill the babies?
Is that going to be our crime today?
Hmm.
I was on back order for your plushie.
I got it today.
Minto!
Thank you.
Unbirth.
Are we going to...
murder babies today because the babies are the descendants so did you have to say unbirth well I don't know what else to call it I'm not quite we're not birthing the babies that's for sure let's see what our girlfriend has to say Brent it's about that conversation we had what is it Brent more questions you're really curious wait do you guys hear an echo or is it mean oh wait can I ask you wait how can we get to the oh can I ask you something personal okay I mean where we might die here so might as well but the whole new meaning on baby food Can I ask you something personal?
That depends on just how personal it is, Brent.
Are you married?
What did you think of me when I first came to your museum?
Do we be direct?
Or do we kind of ask for...
We get a little bit of a...
Let's be direct.
Are you married?
Oh, well, um...
Was that too private a question?
Yes.
No.
Oh, I don't.
know you don't have to answer it's all right brent i was married i got married as soon as i was 18.
you know you know my father dragged one of his younger colleagues round to our house every weekend a real high flyer with money an expensive car and a golf club membership he was called peter peter what do you mean you were don't act so offended and elegant Peter not Peter wait and you married him hmm I mean does he not know what a divorce is what do you mean you were married after our wedding Peter soon changed you know at the beginning he was sort of charming sort of then he became different unpredictable tempered violent he hit you yes it started with a box around the ears.
And then it happened all the time.
You put up with that?
For some time, I did.
I thought, well, that's what it's like to be married.
How long did that go on for?
About two years.
Then I divorced him when I found out that he'd been unfaithful to me with some girls from the golf club all the time.
The golf club.
And did you start studying immediately after getting divorced?
What did your father say to all this?
That must have been a difficult... We could be there for her, and then she would be like, wow, he's so nice.
Thank you for telling me that, okay this is we're shooting our shot we're being considerate and compassionate we're being empathetic we are that must have been a difficult time for you it was hell I was alone broke and I'd had enough of men I can imagine that oh so I have heard from this Peter guy since then after the divorce he behaved like a lunatic for months what he called all the time or he appeared drunk in front of the house and screamed abuse in the middle of the night he even waited for me in the museum and swore at me i had to call the police oh my god god what a psychopath you know what he's doing could it be me yes now and then i read about him in the papers he's a director of the anthropological society now one of the bigwigs he seems to have achieved what he always wanted and as far as i know he's married again but i'm not really that interested in his life all things over for me now i'm just glad to be left in peace are you being empathetic without the Oh,
Melanie, I forgot to tell you my previous name.
Was Peter.
Oh my gosh.
Did you start?
And did you start studying all the tea on Melanie?
Yes, I started working and financed my studies myself.
I wanted to be independent at last, from my father, my husband, from everything that had restricted me before.
I studied like mad.
Like mad.
I spent the nights in the library.
And you were successful.
I didn't have anything left apart from my career.
so I thought make the best of it oh my goodness and it worked yep what did your father what did your father say to all this poor girl right my father wasn't delighted with the divorce he saw how I suffered all the time but he didn't want to believe it oh my god after all the whole this is so out of left field can I just say that I wanted to split up his first concern was that it might harm his research contacts Wow what about your mother I lost my mother a long time ago she had cancer and died very early when I was only nine do you get on well with your father after splitting up with Peter we lost touch for a number of years my father just couldn't understand why I wouldn't do what he wanted anymore he couldn't understand how I could deprive him of his allegedly gorgeous gorgeous son-in-law and I was disappointed in him it was only when I got my degree and we became colleagues so to speak that our relationship Wow.
You have a business relationship with your dad.
Thank you for telling me that, Melanie.
I don't usually talk that much about myself, Brent.
But meanwhile, you've become almost like a friend.
Wait!
Oh, we're almost...
Wait, you guys, we're almost friend-zoned.
We're not friend-zoned yet.
We're almost friend-zoned.
I think that's worse.
It's about that conversation we had.
What is it, Brent?
More questions?
You're really curious.
Could I ask you, wait?
Can you see what's over there on the rocky island?
You mean the tower?
No, I mean the thing in front of the tower.
What?
No idea.
Looks like scales or scaffolding.
What purpose could that serve?
If we stay here, we'll never know.
Acquaintance zone.
How do we get, I guess we just, I don't know why I'm asking this.
I want the dialogue.
Bridges don't look very inviting to me.
Yeah, there's bridges.
Yes, I can see what you mean.
A lot of them have cracks as well.
Nah, it's fine.
It's probably too much of a risk.
Oh, no.
They will collapse one after the other.
What?
No, they're strong.
But we can't just stay here and hope for a miracle either.
We have to do something.
We summon the power of the Druids.
Do you think we could really time travel?
Oh, my God, there's so much.
Did Blake say anything else that could help us?
Oh, Blake!
I don't think so.
Not while I was there, anyway.
were the one who talked to him he only told me that there had been a place of worship at this location for millennia that doesn't help me now that's crazy that's crazy crazy do you think you can really time travel from here scientifically I'd say it's impossible but like you said it's our only chance if this doesn't get us anywhere we're finished we should try everything what what what do you think why was it built like I don't know I'm an anthropologist not an architect our house we will find a way of getting over there i hope so let's go over there let's go over there anything let's go read the sign whoa shrek why did i wait okay oh my god all right good
Why did I take those?
Wait, where are they?
What?
Wait, what?
You guys- It won't work like that.
My screen is... Hold on.
Wait, there's actually something wrong with my screen because I can't see my full inventory.
I was wondering why the subtitles were cut off.
Wait a second.
Why is it different though?
Oh, that's so strange.
Wait.
This is so bizarre.
Is it showing up normal for you guys?
No.
I didn't change anything.
That's why I'm so confused.
Hold on.
One moment, please.
I'm so sorry.
Huh.
Why did the resolution change?
What?
Why did it change?
Look, this is normal.
Huh.
Did Lego Indy screw up your resolution?
I don't think so.
Oh, no.
Because I used a different capture for last stream.
This is so weird.
It looks wider than usual.
Yeah, it is wider than usual.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm extremely confused right now.
Why it suddenly went to widescreen.
I wonder if it's maybe this part of the game for some reason.
Well, now I need to move myself a little bit, I think.
Let's let's do that.
Huh.
You could say it's a mystery of the druid.
I'm actually so confused right now.
Well, I'm sorry.
I started.
up the game with with it not being a widescreen but I didn't know so I've been playing and the game has been fine this whole time okay so we got boards of the danger sign the boards of the danger sign okay this is very strange he's
walking so slowly and like at varying intervals of hello is he ever gonna reach it as a professional computer I can tell you the reason this happened is because computers are haunted I'll invoice you later um no no no no no this haunting is is spoken for you stay out this is my territory arched bridges must be ancient wait no no I want to talk to her I good place for me to be.
I'm like blacking everything.
It's about that conversation we had.
What is it, Brent?
More questions?
You're really curious.
Okay, I think, uh, okay, this is all the stuff we asked before.
Um, there's these arched bridges must be ancient.
Must be ancient.
There's a rather strange building over there.
Mm-hmm.
Arched bridges.
That must be ancient, I think.
Wait, so how do we, get over there.
Just walk.
Like, this one looks completely safe.
Oh, yeah, there we go.
Awesome.
Now I hear the echo.
Yeah, okay, run.
Don't walk.
Run.
Nice.
Oh, yeah, we can totally make it.
Oh, my God.
Don't stand so close to me.
Hello?
Is there something that I'm supposed to notice here?
Melanie?
Brent?
Oh my god, no!
What is it, Brent?
More questions?
You're really curious.
He's too curious!
Which one?
Let's see, I'm searching for anything.
Do you use the boards for something?
That would make maybe too much sense.
I should think about it again.
Hmm.
so about your divorce how much did you cry do you need an arm do you need a shoulder to cry on okay what am I supposed to do here hmm guys I think I'm gonna sorry I'm so confused about why the game is suddenly big so I'm going to make it smaller I'm so sorry I don't know why it's like this Wait,
can I?
Oh, yeah, I can.
What the?
Is that...
This is awkward.
Is it too weird looking?
I'm so annoyed right now.
Yeah, see?
She's cut off.
Why?
So bizarre.
How bizarre?
I don't understand.
I'm sorry.
I'm actually, like, so confused.
But that's okay.
We're here.
And I'm going to figure out what to do.
We're searching.
It's so quiet.
The music does not loop for some reason.
Melanie, does your divorce have anything to do with these bridges?
widescreen.
Yeah, exactly.
Can you squeeze it to 4-3 and OBS?
That's what, that's what, that's what this is.
This is my 4-3.
But, it like, does, it, for some reason it's cutting off now.
That's so mysterious.
I can't get over it.
And the weirder thing is, it doesn't look...
like stretched out maybe it doesn't look but it's so weird sorry okay i'm fine we're fine everything's fine i think the game switched the widescreen i think so too maybe for a mysterious effect maybe okay walk walk over it oh what the heck am i supposed to do here read the runes read them go back go back
I tried the wood planks nothing happened unless I didn't put it in the right spot but this is like the only place I can go unless there's something over here
hmm unless I miss like a side area over here or something oh Oh my god, there's nobody even going back.
Like, this is it.
This is it.
There's nowhere to go from here.
Hmm.
The true mystery of the druids was widescreen.
Maybe, like, they're the first to ever do widescreen.
And they're, like, showing it off.
They're like, well, this is it.
We're the first.
Okay, so it's definitely something right here.
With the planks.
Unless we're pixel hunting.
so ahead of there that
looks even more dangerous why are you just standing there this looks way more dangerous than anything else
no way this is way less sturdy than just using the bridge good heavens that was close oh my god are you okay yes I'm all right you've got a nerve Brent Halligan how dare you upset me like that what I do you could have got killed it's all right Melanie I'm still alive don't you ever do that again do you hear me hey all right He didn't cause the bridge to...
Wait, how is she gonna get over here now?
Wait a second.
Wait.
Halligan, we're just leaving her.
Wait, how is that Melanie supposed to cross?
Okay, I'm going one plank at a time.
Very slowly.
Caution, danger indeed.
This is so dumb.
Oh.
Okay, Melanie, good luck.
Melanie?
I made it.
I'm on the other side.
Great, Brent.
What's it like over there?
Interesting.
There's a rather strange tower with some sort of scales in front of it.
No idea what it's used for.
Come here and see for yourself.
I can't, Brent.
You've got both boards on your side.
Yeah, idiot.
Oh, damn.
That's true.
Brent, how much do you weigh?
What?
How much do you weigh?
Your weight.
About 160 pounds.
Why do you want to know?
A hundred and...
A hundred and sixty pounds?
I'm coming over now?
Melanie, don't...
Stop at once.
The bridge will collapse.
Oh my god, no, Melanie, don't do it!
Melanie, no!
No, Melanie!
Oh my god, wait.
Oh my god, no sense of urgency.
She just walked like she was in a fashion show.
Melanie.
Okay, that was fine.
Good job.
Melanie, how dare you do that?
Here we are.
What shall we do now?
She slayed.
I'd say we have to get into the tower.
Oh gosh, more personal questions.
Could I ask you something personal?
That depends on just how personal it is, Brenna.
What did you think of me?
What did you think of me when I first came to your museum?
It's average for a shorter guy.
Oh, yeah?
Do I really have to tell you?
Of course you don't have to.
But I'd like to know.
I'll tell you, but only if you promise not to be angry with me.
Uh-oh.
Oh, God.
Is it that bad?
Well, do you promise?
Uh-oh.
Yeah, yeah.
Lay it on me.
Be honest.
Okay.
I promise.
I thought this unshaven bloke's wearing a totally unfashionable coat.
What?
what that's what you thought yes and was that all you thought you asked a lot of questions brent i think that's enough for a start perhaps we can chat a bit more later now we've got other problems as well don't you think sure more than enough i would say
oh this guy i it was uh that all you thought what is this oh Slicking his hair back.
That looks like scales.
But what are they used for?
What do you mean scales?
Is this not like brick?
Why do they keep calling it scales?
Or do they mean like the vines growing up?
The door is completely flat.
No handle, no lock.
Nothing.
Just like me, for real, for real.
Really strange this building.
How?
Did you think there was something of a handsome...
man under the cup.
That looks like scales, but what are they used for?
Oh, like a waking scale.
I'm thinking like a dragon.
I was like, what do you mean?
Scale.
English is hard, you guys, please.
I'm crying.
No.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, man.
Wait, can we climb in here get in there or wait maybe I can put in the amulet wait does this actually work oh oh my
gosh I'm maybe I'm thinking like a druid for real it's that how heavy is it I know right okay let's go in that's too dangerous wait Why?
That's too dangerous.
I got it open.
There's a wheel up there.
I opened it.
Why is it too dangerous?
Maybe...
Oh!
That's too dangerous.
Still?
Um...
Never change, Vito Brun.
Yeah.
Is there something else I can add to it?
Nothing's happening.
It might need the amulet.
You think so?
Maybe we put something else in there instead.
Grab this.
Oh, wait!
If we take it and then it closes...
Aha!
Okay.
Now we can enter!
The case file.
Always the case file.
Oh, we've faded into the...
Elaborate floor ornaments.
Goodbye.
Weren't there similar symbols in Sinclair's house?
Yes, it was...
Campfire to the right.
That's all I remember.
another tub empty again oh wait put it in that's futile as well why it worked before no better not not a good idea oh okay oh god um elaborate floor ornaments
spiky air on the bottom spiky air on the bottom and then it was the wavy air it was the river on the left so that means it was it was this this no no I'm help help help Melanie help a Melanie Melanie is silenced Melanie cannot speak in in front of the tub another tub empty again
Anything else?
Little window.
The arrow slits are exactly in the direction of the bridges.
It was possible to defend this building perfectly.
Oh.
Wait, can I put them like in here?
No, not in the slots, no.
I thought it wouldn't work like that.
Oh, okay.
Then why'd you try?
Why'd you try?
I thought it wouldn't work like that.
Oh.
Melanie speak!
What's wrong with you?
She's possessed!
Oh my god!
Possessed Melanie!
Oh, ouch.
Oh, sorry if you heard that.
Wouldn't... No, it wouldn't be this one.
I can't tell which... I can't see the other ones in the back.
And then...
We also can't see this one down here.
How are we supposed to know what it looks like?
Hmm.
in Sinclair's house.
I mean, similar symbols in Sinclair's.
Why are there similar symbols in Sinclair's house?
Has Halligan been holding on to a painting frame this entire time?
Yes, he has.
Actually, I don't...
That won't get me any further.
I don't know why we have it.
We've also been holding on to broken scissors two pairs.
the bone the bone this guy's fishing rod that we stole this crazy alcoholic apple juice fingerprint dust pocket sand can you imagine um elaborate floor ornaments wait but they're like different angles now that i look at it than what
Why do I... what am I supposed to do here?
Maybe I give the bone.
Eat up!
No, not a chance.
I'm more sure...
Oh, wait!
No way.
Oh, okay.
What about here?
Hmm.
That doesn't work.
There?
Hmm.
Nothing's happening.
Root fullers?
No way.
I should think up something else.
Okay, just kidding.
What's this pole?
I just don't get why the tub was screwed to the metal bar.
Yeah, me neither.
Oh?
There's no point in that.
Oh, dang it, I thought it was to the bar.
They all have the burger icon pointing to the bar.
the center.
This one?
Which means, oh, you're right.
So this is all at the top.
This one and this one have the campfire on the correct side.
So does this one.
Are they all the same?
Wait a second, they're all the same.
Now I look.
Wait, they're all the same.
It's not like a pick the correct one.
Oh, my gosh.
I just...
What?
But it's different from the one that was at Sinclair's.
Um...
Hmm.
Doesn't fit.
Would have surprised me anyway.
Can you get in here?
Get in the tub.
And give us a show.
How again?
Another tub.
Empty again.
What else can I put in here?
No.
I would have...
only scratch everything.
Oh my god, he's still concerned about scratching everything with the needle.
And there's nowhere else for me to go.
Melanie, why won't you say anything?
I'm lost!
Random item into the tub.
We start from the case files.
That won't get me any further.
Think first, Brent.
I'm trying.
No.
better not that is no important evidence I'm sure about that won't feel different with gloves either that won't get me any further oh it's got to be the fishing rod that won't help either think Brent think no better not better not I should think about it again I don't think it's anything you were on the right track to put the amulet in the tub I got a pixel hunt no way but like it's That would be stupid.
I should think up.
That does like.
There's no.
I can't think.
Looks like no way.
I don't want.
I should think.
No.
I thought that won't get me any further.
Think first, Brent.
Not a good idea.
That won't.
Hmm.
No.
I should think.
Looks like that won't work.
I don't want that.
I did look outside.
There was really nothing.
Hmm.
It would have surprised me if it had worked like that.
It wouldn't have surprised me.
That doesn't work.
That won't get me in no way.
I'd rather think that won't.
It won't work.
No, of course.
It can't work like that.
I'll have to grab the...
Wait.
Will it let me?
No, it won't let me grab the...
Wait, do I...
Oh, wait, or this board over here.
Wait, I can't...
I can't grab this board.
Um, am I getting one guide?
I can't tell.
Imagine being Melanie standing there listening to Brent talk, pass talk through.
Is that what work up?
Melanie followed.
Really strange this building?
There's, wait, no.
Really strange this building.
I'm talking about the building.
There's really nothing else over here.
Like out around here.
That looks like scales.
But what are they used for?
I keep thinking dragon skills.
I like how we like fade from existence when we...
Yeah, it won't let me pick up the board that's in front of the door.
So, maybe I got one guide.
I'm gonna look up a walkthrough.
The mystery of the druids walkthrough.
Oh, do we need help?
That's why I'm looking it up.
All good.
Oh, oh, oh, okay, okay.
Part four.
Wait, no, not part four.
We're at part...
Wait, huh?
Oh, wait.
Part 2.
Okay, part 3.
What?
Where does it start?
Oh, we're not at part 3 yet.
Okay.
Two planks.
Put the...
Put the amulet...
In the bucket.
Use the board to keep the door.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, go!
Oh!
I have to go!
Go to the bucket.
Unscrew the screw outside of the left side of the bucket.
Oh my god.
Wait.
This one?
It's so slow and it sounds horrible.
Hurry up!
And get the hook and screw.
Okay.
I also have to get the hook.
Okay, we got it.
Definitely knew that I...
If they needed this for their contraption, why did they not keep it in the room?
Squeak, squeak, squeak!
Click the board near the door to close the door.
It won't let me, though.
It really won't.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
This.
Hey, look at that.
This building.
is really something.
An hourglass.
This building is a card?
Is that what the subtitles just said?
Wait!
Is this the time travel?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright, so I'm gonna not look at the walkthrough anymore until I need help.
I think probably I put this in here.
No?
Just kidding.
I put this in here.
No?
Okay, just kidding.
What do I do?
Wait a sec.
Eel?
I said I would not look until I need more help we're fine wait there's got to be more that I can look at no okay
oh whoa why whoa it's like changes perspectives whoa whoa whoa What's this?
Does this let me leave?
Oh, oh, okay, it's telling me different directions.
Maybe I put the emulate in this side.
So what did I need these for?
The runes.
So there's two different sides.
Oh, I thought
Amulet.
And clicking on it.
Oh, he doesn't say anything.
Oh,
back to square one.
Oh.
Hold on.
It allows me to do something here.
So maybe we have to hook something in here.
Screw it, maybe?
What can I unscrew it with?
The nail.
Why doesn't he say anything?
I don't...
Ah!
I can't see a key for the door of the tower room in Sinclair's villa.
Ew.
What the heck?
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Can I combine these?
Some phrase?
No way.
Why?
A hook.
What do you mean?
Why no way?
There's no point.
I don't want that.
Why no way?
way as if like this is totally I can't do that out of the question as if that's not how we just found them
click use the scissors sorry
oh no maybe I put the amulet in now no
wait there's a there's another side hold on let's go to the other side i need scissors 61
oh it's like that okay
mellony mellony mellony Hold my hand
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Brent!
Brent!
I
think we're traveling through time
I had to take a second to to catch their breath, you know?
Good morning, Melanie Good morning, Brento
Why did that work?
We haven't moved even a single inch from where we started, have we?
Look, the bridge is a hole again.
If you ask me, the bridges are still hole.
We've landed in a time when this whole place was still completely intact.
They've gone to the cinema with me, we've traveled back in time.
Do you really think so?
Uh-oh, here comes company.
Oh.
Hello.
They look like soldiers.
Oh, panic.
Let's find out what they want.
Oh, I
must have fainted.
Where are we now?
What do you mean, fainted?
Friend, are you there?
Damn, where am I?
Looks like a kitchen.
Oh, my gosh.
She's just thinking everything all at once very quickly.
Oh, it looks like scales.
Like a dragon.
They're broken.
Oh, my gosh.
Does she not remember getting punched by...
A large cauldron.
There's some liquid in it.
What's in there?
Oh, the music is funky.
What's over here?
Oh, I got something?
What is this?
A weed.
Or maybe a herb.
It smells of menthol.
A weed!
These jugs smell good.
There must be dried leaves.
I don't know which plant they come from.
I'm grabbing everything.
Okay.
Uh, oh.
What we got?
I should concentrate.
Sorry, sorry.
This weed feels strange.
Almost like a sponge.
That smells of aniseed.
Those leaves are sort of fleshy.
Maybe they come from a herbaceous plant.
This herb smells of cinnamon.
Dried leaves.
Interesting.
We're gonna cook.
Did they put her in the kitchen because she's a lady?
They were like, who's this guy?
I don't know.
Take the female to the kitchen.
She'll finish supper.
Okay, we got a bowl.
Okay, we've got so much going on here.
Oh, what's this here?
What the hell?
We're just gonna ignore this drip?
What is that?
It is the past, after all.
That's what I'm saying.
There's no sense of organization here.
Maybe we make them a sleepy stew.
What is this?
Oh, okay.
What did I grab?
The medieval book of recipes.
Let's see what it says.
To make a good drink.
Wait.
To make a strange...
Slipping drink.
Wait, should we make them...
The sleeping drink or the meat or the good drink?
Minky.
That's me.
Maybe the sleeping drink.
What is a pate of fish?
When was the last day?
Great question.
Let's save.
My game is so stretched now.
Minto 19.
Uh-oh.
Hopefully there's not a crazy strain of it.
Okay, hold on.
The medieval book of recipes.
Let's see what it says.
Fisk is fish?
Oh, it is?
Forever 19!
Let's see, let's try the sleeping one.
To make a strang slapping drank, tack 12 ounces of crimson and an ounce of the golden.
Mix 12 ounces of the green fram and... Oh, what the hell is this?
Wait, what?
2 ounces of the crimson and an ounce of the golden.
Two ounce of the green fram, an ounce, and an ounce.
What does this mean?
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh no, I didn't mean to press that.
Fish, fish scarring, skiering them.
Ooh, well, we don't have fish.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Okay, get me out of here, please.
What's...
Maybe I could start cooking.
I say this is water.
Oh, it's water, okay.
Two ounce of the golden?
This herb smells of cinnamon, dried leaves.
I don't know which plant they come from.
A weed, or maybe a herb.
This weed feels strange.
That smells of aniseed.
I don't... I don't know.
Is that blood on the ground?
Oh, oh.
Looks like there's been a feast here recently.
Wow.
Can I have some?
Hello.
What have we here then?
Look, John, the Danish whores woken up.
Oh,
point one.
Point one, I'm not a whore.
Point two, I'm not Danish.
Do you hear that?
She's got a sharp tongue in her head.
If you're not Danish, what are you?
That's none of your business.
Oh, isn't it?
You and your friend just come strolling into our kingdom right from the forbidden place, and it's none of our business to know who you are.
Danish pastry.
You have no right to hold us here.
We're just harmless travellers.
Let us go.
Oh, you'd like that, wouldn't you?
You two are staying right here until you've told us what your mission is.
when the invasion is due to begin.
Invasion?
What invasion?
What invasion, damn it!
I know nothing of an invasion, and neither does Brent.
You know very well what I'm talking about.
The next Danish invasion.
But I promise you this.
This time, King Ethel Red will be ready.
We will slaughter you the moment you set foot on English soil.
Um, I'm Dr. Melanie Turner.
Uh, I don't think he'll care about that.
My friend and I don't belong here.
We...
There you are.
A confession at last.
No, no.
What I mean is we don't belong to this time.
My God, is there no way I can get you to understand?
This is madness.
We're not Danish.
We're English.
We're English!
You are, are you?
Then tell me this.
Uh-oh.
Where in England did Edward the most...
martyr rule.
Who?
Damn it, how should I know?
I've never been interested in medieval history.
After all, all that ended over a thousand years ago.
Why is she acting like...
Is she stupid?
She's mad.
This woman's completely mad.
She's having us on.
Stop talking nonsense.
Was that in the books?
Tidy up and see you got something to drink.
He's not gonna care.
What about this guy?
What are you staring at me for?
Never seen a woman before.
What's she mean, Thomas?
She means you're a fool, John.
I've never seen a lady before.
If I try to leave, will they kill me?
These lads seem to be pretty violent.
Hey!
Oh!
Stop!
You've no business going down there.
Do you hear?
You violated the law.
Yeah, isn't she an anthropologist?
maybe she doesn't care about well she's an evil history where are drinks damn it I couldn't find any wine or meat in the kitchen what John you numbskull I thought I told you to go to the market and buy some provisions why me blast it let her go the ladies so-and-so do you want her to escape what a fool you are don't call me a fool then don't be a fool then I won't call you one oh she said don't call me a fool excuse me what do you want what do you want me to get you i don't care damn it think of something bring us something to drink bring us tea we'll go and buy some provisions when we finished interrogating your friend when will that be i'm angry i'm angry just shut up will you shut up john i could offer you something other than i could offer you something other than tea Oh,
what's that?
Oh, a love potion.
Why would it...
A love potion?
Why would you say that?
I'm my own recipe.
Oh, well, that doesn't sound too vain.
Is he lonely?
You're not so much of a cow as I thought you were.
Is this not witchcraft?
To be honest, I've always had a soft spot for men who know what they want.
Hey, I like that.
Why don't you just come a little closer?
All right.
What'd you make of that, John?
It's quite tame, really.
What wonderful equipment you have, soldier.
Yes, isn't it just...
What's happening?
And it's all been christened with the blood of my enemies.
Take a good look, if you like, and then bring the...
that potion you were talking about you'll have to be patient i must brew it first
love potion our little man is so lonely and sad what is this i've always found pictures of wars revolting this isn't picture this isn't like a photo it's a it's a it's art they so freaky they are The dragon!
I've always found pictures of wars revolting.
This is so tame.
I like this guy's little club.
It's nice.
What's in here?
I might have guessed.
The door's locked.
Is that bread?
Looks like there's been a feast here recently.
Okay.
Yeah, they're dragon scales.
Finally.
Okay, so we need to fix this.
Oh, wait.
I think I can...
fix it with one of the um with this there we go okay now we know what is an ounce and two ounce i guess i don't know anything else i don't i don't know the recipe the medieval book of recipes let's see what it says yeah it's not a wizard hat it's a druid hat okay sleep and drink yes take twa ounce in of the crimson and ounce of the golden mix twa ounce in of the green fram that hard drink made the beat of sleep good turn to fuse that sleeping love potion with plenty of moly-moly Q and energy of course of course there is no red oh I
thought you were talking about your wizard role hat no talking about my my druid hat I thought about cinnamon being red those leaves are sort of fleshy no fleshy maybe they come from a herbaceous plant fleshy this herb smells of cinnamon yeah did you check every jar I did I'll check again though I clicked on every single one these jugs smell good there must be herbs or spices in them I click on every single one Yeah,
no...
It's in here?
Anything?
No?
Okay.
Okay, hold on.
I'm consulting.
Oh my god!
I have the pixel hunt in here.
Look at this.
John!
Ah!
Celebrations are due!
Our pay has arrived!
Ten pieces of silver for each of us!
Oh!
polished pieces of silver at one ounce each you again silver one ounce what do you want now I told you to hurry up and serve us
um what can I get wait there's something I need to ask you there's something I need to ask you I don't know what it is and something I'd like to make clear go ahead what have you done to Brent what have you done to Brent do you hear that John she wants to know yeah you did to the lad that was with her oh the us is worried about him you must like him a lot hey John what did you do to the poor man oh just chopped off his ears still don't look bad though what you monsters now now John's in a good mood today he always jokes around when he's in a mood like that your friend's unarmed for the moment anyway what are you going to do to him unless he tells us what day your king's planning to start his invasion he won't be feeling too good and he lose a few more body parts than just his ears depend on it okay so they get the money.
Well, my little dove, how's my potion give?
My little dove.
It's nearly ready.
I'll bring it along in a minute.
Okay, wait.
I have to get that money, though.
Is it this?
Thank you very much.
How many did I grab?
An old English coin weighing one ounce exactly.
But I need two ounces.
wait can I get another one wait hold on let's try no dang okay let's not talk to him because he might realize his his money's gone okay yes um all right let's look at this recipe one more time medieval book of recipes medieval what it says medieval slap and drank okay all right Alright guys,
let's put our brains together.
Two ounce of crimson, ounce of the golden.
Me...
It's...
What's a green fram?
That's the one thing.
I think the crimson...
Uh?
This weed feels strange.
Almost like a sponge.
It doesn't help that they all look so similar.
I don't know which plant they come from.
Maybe this is golden, you know?
it looks kind of gold right
that's exactly one ounce of the herb okay
screw it we're gonna try the cinnamon as the Christmas of cinnamon we're gonna try the cinnamon as the crimson okay cinnamon right that's exactly one ounce of the herb okay one more okay I will save before I give this to them by the way don't worry right that's exactly one ounce of the herb okay the medieval book of recipes let's see what it says okay if Fram is from okay we got the two ounces of cinnamon and ounce of the golden mix the two of the green from an ounce and an ounce wait what wait what an ounce and an ounce do I mix them in here I should try and think of something else oh maybe this this cup what if you actually make a love potion I know okay we're just gonna stick that in my pocket this hot water this weed makes the water turn red okay but what what was that okay wait this is good now it's turned into a brown slop that's probably um that's probably the gold would turn it a little more right
Yeah, slop!
Give me more slop!
Oh, oopsie.
I just pressed the wrong thing.
One moment, please.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, now I save.
Save game.
Me until 20.
You guys are watching me grow up in real time.
Wait, the brown slop is both correct and incorrect at once.
The failure state for the puzzle looks exactly the same as the success.
Well, here's hoping.
Here you are, gentlemen.
What's this revolting liquid?
It looks like latrine water.
Are you trying to poison us?
No.
he'll drink it here you are gentlemen what's this revolting liquid it looks like latrine water are you trying to poison us keep it i
think this is probably a place to dump it yep that's what i figured okay okay let's see let's okay now though we know that we can test the herbs and see what color they make them so what we can do is well obviously i just want to see what color this was you know we gotta find the gold okay it's so slow though it's so slow all right exactly one ounce of the herb now the water is completely yellow is that not gold wait
But it's not right.
What the heck?
Can I get rid of this?
I wish I could so that I don't have to like...
Then what about...
This one?
Read the recipe again.
Why?
Wait, when you do the mixing, you will have the brown color, but keep mixing and you get the correct potion.
there's no point in that wait what the medieval book of recipes let's see what it says
okay take two ounce of the crimson ounce of the golden mixing ounce uh
I didn't say I needed to add more than two wait what wait
you only had two ounce in total you need three oh no what do you what do you mean I had two ounce of the I made the two ounce of the of the cinnamon I think from my understanding of this it's saying two ounces of the cinnamon two ounces of the golden and then mix the two ounces wait of the green what wait we just learned something to make it green though wait what what turned green what turned green was it this one the
water in the bowl is absolutely clear okay Thank you.
Okay, well, we know the red.
Those leaves are sort of flat.
This herb smells of cinnamon.
Okay, so cinnamon is the other gold one.
So, perhaps...
Okay, what I'm going to do is add this immediately, because maybe it didn't count it as a second ounce as well, as what I was thinking, too.
Right.
That's exactly one ounce of the herb.
So if I put it in now...
This weed makes the water turn red.
And now we do it again.
This herb smells of cinnamon.
So we do this.
Oh, wait.
I don't know which one turned green.
Uh, that's fine.
That's exactly one ounce of the herb.
Okay, now I mix two.
Combine.
Okay, I'm looking it up.
Cinnamon two ounces of weight.
I have to do...
Two ounces of the dried leaves, and then one ounce of aniseed.
Was it this one?
Those leaves are sort of flesh.
That smells of aniseed.
I remember I picked either this one or this one to just randomly throw into the bowl.
Okay, so this is the...
One ounce of this, and then we need two ounces of green.
Spooky, welcome back!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
That's exactly one ounce of the herb.
Okay.
color so that was our golden well no that was our wait i'm getting confused what two ounces yeah that was our golden one i guess it makes it makes the same color wait which a weed or maybe a herb those leaves are sort of fleshy maybe dried leaves i don't know which plant they come from why do i need two ounces of this i'm confused
Now I need two ounces of this, according to walkthrough Sama.
That's exactly one ounce of the herb.
According to the powers that have bestowed this knowledge upon me.
Right.
This is...
That's exactly one...
The water in the bowl is absolutely clear.
did that nope that's not how that should uh color theory
okay yeah that ought to get you going hmm it looks good anyway what is it as i said a love potion just trust her it doesn't taste all that good but it'll work go just wait and see i should hope so because I'm getting tired.
Very tired.
Sipi Han?
Well, they're still drinking it.
If I leave and go back, will they be asleep?
No?
Well, is it working yet?
I can't feel anything yet.
In fact, I'm still dog tired.
Get us another one!
I have to make it again!
No, kid.
Are you serious right now?
No!
Are you serious?
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
This herb smells of cinnamon.
Oh my god.
Weeks of fun.
Everybody, aren't you having just so much fun.
Weeks and weeks and weeks of potion after potion.
That's exactly one ounce of the This weed makes the water turn red.
This herb smells of cinnamon.
Weeks of fun!
All his brain cells cooking!
You'll never...
You'll never want to play anything else!
That's exactly one ounce of the herb.
That smells of aniseed.
Right.
That's exactly one ounce of the herb.
Weeks of fun!
Devs considered this recipe really important.
I guess we really just got it.
We got to make sure they're knocked out.
Oh, if only we were...
That's exactly one ounce of the herb.
If only we were Brent, we would give them the apple drink.
My potions are too weak for me, traveler.
Right.
That's exactly one ounce of the herb.
her the water in the bowl is absolute okay please fall asleep now that should do it sweet dreams my friends
that should do it sweet dreams my friends
why did I make a second one Brent Melanie at last I'm here over here over here at last wasn't I quick enough for you.
This really is one hell of a rat's nest.
Where are we anyway?
I think this is an outpost of the British Army.
It seems a number of wars were fought in this area a thousand years ago.
Great.
That's simply wonderful, isn't it?
Maybe we should have read a few history books before we came here.
Where are the soldiers now?
Why are you getting so sniffy?
Wait, his ears are totally intact.
I made them a drink that seems to have had the desired effect.
He has his... Well done, Melanie.
Now let's get out of here.
Unlock the door.
Oh, I haven't.
The key.
Oh.
I haven't got the key.
Oh, great.
You'd better look for it then.
It must be around here somewhere.
I'm really fed up with sitting in this hole.
All right, all right.
Calm down, will you?
I'm looking.
I'll be right back.
Be quick.
He's such a jerk!
I would understand if he was like in...
He certainly have enough weapons around here.
If he was in pain, you know?
He's well prepared for an invasion.
Not that it's any of my business.
But very clearly, they did nothing to his ears.
They're empty.
What's in here?
Wait, before I do this, I'm going to save.
Save the game.
I think we're 21 now.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
I saw a rat!
I can't open it.
Um.
What about with...
Okay, I have nothing.
Okay.
Uh...
Grab that.
Grab this.
To pry it open?
No?
None of those are good ideas?
It's just hangry because there's no pizza.
No pizza!
Um...
Anything here that could pry it open?
This?
I should try and think of something else.
Weapons.
Oh...
Uh...
What about this?
No?
Pizza.
This one?
No?
Ew.
I might have guessed.
The door's locked.
Oh, I don't think the guards have the key.
I think they want us to open that.
I don't think I saw anything in here.
Little ladle do?
This thing?
No, what?
That looks perfect for opening a crate?
At least we know there's no vampires in here.
They certainly have enough weapons around here.
Looks like they're empty.
Nothing on this side, it seems.
I can't open it.
Okay.
Door opening potion.
Uh...
Just...
How you doing in there?
Well, have you found the key?
Not yet, Brent.
But I will.
I will.
I hope so.
We could use it to bust down the door.
We could use it to open the bust down...
I don't know.
Wait, oh wait!
Oh, I keep thinking of items that Brent has.
Ah, because I was like, oh, scissors.
I don't know.
Look at the little ragu.
Can you search the men?
I didn't see anything.
Now let me search them.
That should do it.
Sweet dreams, my that should do it.
Sweet dreams, my friends.
Bones?
Looks like there's been a feast here recently.
Why can't you grab this?
Weapon.
It won't work like that.
Why not?
Is that a key right here?
Looks like there's been a feast here recently.
No, unfortunately.
Good eye though.
I saw your vision.
And I have like, I only have herbs in my inventory, so there's nothing.
Nothing that I can...
Like, use the knife or something.
Love potion on Brent, I wish.
Guy loves himself too much.
Well, already.
Sorry, I had to wake up early today, and I'm a little sleepy.
They're empty.
Okay, walk through.
Tell me what you got.
Wait, I do have to click...
Wait, he does have the key?
but where i did click on him what is it what is this what i did oh my god
into the oh la la am i just like clicking the wrong things oh what just happened uh one second oh oh oh my bad
My bud.
We're fine.
Oh, my game crashed!
One second.
Oops.
No, no, no, no.
Um, wouldn't this be so funny?
No.
Load game.
21.
weeks of fun no we're fine we're fine we have music again
we're back where we were I accidentally pressed windows and every time you go out you tab out of the game it crashes the game guys I've had a bajillion and one problem setting up this game okay I can't open it.
Maybe I have to get him out first.
Maybe I do get him out and then I figure out what to do.
But it was so worth it.
I'm so happy to play this game.
Okay, now how do we get out of here?
The door's upstairs.
Wait here.
I'll go and see whether the key fits the other door.
Look at him go- Oh, look how cute he is!
Bing bong, bong.
Feels a little laggy, but...
Uh, this door?
Wait, this door...
This one?
Here we go.
It won't work like that, I don't think.
You literally just said you would check.
Don't bullshit me, Melanie.
There's no other door.
What do you mean?
It won't work like that, I think.
I'm gonna push you down these stairs.
Okay, I'm just gonna say what I saw in the walkthrough.
Give me a hand with this crate, Brent.
It's too heavy for me to shift on my own.
Bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
Ah, just as I thought.
What?
You can look at this, Brent.
As you thought?
I thought there must be more than just one way out of here.
Looks like a secret passage.
Just as I thought.
Don't...
pretty dark down there isn't it are you scared scared nonsense come on let's go there were torches upstairs we can we can we can go to oh oh we have to decide left or right you guys left or right left
Brent I'm here I can hardly see a thing neither can I maybe we ought to go back think rubbish there's no one here don't worry we'll find the way out left or right left or right maybe I should have saved before doing this left there's not a glimmer of light here anywhere Brent oh what was that are you still there Brent Brent this isn't funny hello is that you Brent oh wait was that a one wait what just happened
damn it huh now where am i
oh no we're gonna get skeletonized this is all so familiar my head into that thank you very much this is all so familiar this is no use to an empty plate oh no i'd break my neck climbing down there storehouse and workshop the inner courtyard my arms aren't and work my arms aren't long enough my arms aren't long enough oh my god hello so you are the stranger who came to us through the gate of the world we meet at last i am very pleased to see he knows oh yes i can't say the feeling's mutual i want to get out of here this minute who are you anyway hush be calm nothing will happen to you here i am your friend my friend that's a lie i can do happened in there we need you you are the one all our hopes are hanging on what's that you've been expecting me that's impossible i came here from the year 2000 you can't even know i exist you came to us through the gate of the world not much has changed but we live underwater the course of history and your great great great grandson is eating humans
right now i don't even know where i You are in a monastery, the final refuge of the last Druids of Britain.
You have come to us in our greatest hour of need.
We got to kill all you guys.
Our order is facing extinction.
For thousands of years, we have been handing our knowledge down from generation to generation.
Every pupil was instructed by his mentor for 20 years, until he was worthy of being taught all the secrets of the Druids.
And finally, he would become a mentor himself.
I see.
And?
good or evil.
The mentor's teaching alone determines which side will prevail.
A pupil without a mentor is left to his own devices.
He acts without wisdom or knowledge and thus becomes hungry for power and evil.
Such a lust for power and evil.
Okay that's old news so far.
Our Grand Master Sirsten killed his mentor and became evil yet he succeeded in becoming the leader he became evil he is now preparing a ritual mightier than any that has ever been performed he wishes to transfer the entire brotherhood's power he does look like five infants that guy just like the power of the druids will live on these infants will be stronger than any druid the world has ever seen a true descendant without a mentor.
They are destined for evil.
They will be tyrants.
Mighty, immortal, invincible.
Sounds familiar.
Together, we can prevent this from happening.
A small circle of brothers have united under my leadership with the intention of stopping Sursden.
Alligat is a pupil without a mentor.
His crimes make sense.
But?
Sursden seems to suspect something is going on.
Ever since Since we occupied this monastery, he has been building fortifications to prevent anyone but himself from entering the places of worship.
We know there is a secret room where he keeps a crystal ball.
We also know that Searston has had our temples close to the river altered.
With your help, we will get past its fortifications.
Why do you need my help for that?
We are few.
And Searston is having us watched.
We need somebody of equal power to him.
And you think that's me?
Your journey here has given you the power to alter the course of history.
True, true.
That is more than any of us would be capable of doing.
Find the room that harbors the crystal ball.
I have arranged for you to be allowed to move freely within the monastery until the day of your execution.
Execution?
The day of my execution?
Oh, great.
Now you tell me.
I must leave you now.
I bid you good luck.
Hey, where will I find you?
Thank you, Naomi Hunter.
I am called Maglore.
Maglore.
Oh, great.
Naomi Hunter!
That is, if I ever get to tell him.
And Melanie will...
Hold on.
Where did she get to?
Melanie!
Oh my gosh.
Can I take a nap?
What am I doing?
Oh, just stuffing that in my pocket.
A bed hard as rock.
oh what is that a bird's nest that little fellow can fly I can't I'll never get there like this the Naomi hunter's first descendant there's a bird's nest on the chimney can we call the bird I'd have to go down there to do anything it's too far away there are vegetables growing over there look at that island too far away the sea the sea the sea is quite calm why it said it's silent as a grave but the subtitle the sea is quite calm i think they started getting a little lazy towards the end of the game well he said that i can leave so
melanie oh magle maglore is that your name when i'm when you are there you are i've been looking for you have you discovered anything yet i have to learn how to find my way around here first.
Don't you think you might be able to show me around the monastery?
Out of the question.
We should not be seen together.
We will make sure that Sirstan's spies do not bother you.
Everything else is up to you.
How long do I have?
What have you done with Melanie Turner?
She is safe.
She is true.
It's magic.
What do you mean for the moment?
The day of her execution is the same day when your life will end.
That sounds really encouraging.
A double execution.
so to speak.
And when will that be?
Serstan has decreed that the day of the ritual shall be the day you both die.
Oh.
Where's Melanie now?
Yeah.
She may move freely within the monastery.
Okay, okay.
Just like you.
I have been to see her and told her everything.
I do not know where she is now.
Oh, so she's just wandering around too?
I believe she wanted to take a look around the library.
The library?
We are sentenced to death and Melanie Turner goes to look at the library?
Okay.
I'm sure I'll find her.
See you later.
I'll see you later.
we got here what is it looks like someone does a lot of writing here okay the fire's gone out i can't light it i need some matches to do that don't i have i stole oh i what did i use them on i don't remember i took them from the office no nerd alert i think there are better moments to take a nap than this one nah this is the best time to take a nap oh yeah i burned the bush that's Let's check out this one.
Oh my gosh, this place is huge.
What is this?
Not a pretty sight.
No.
What is it?
That?
What is- What is- what is this?
This place isn't- Crates.
Perfectly ordinary crates.
This place isn't infested with rats.
It's too high up.
Anyway, it's- Oh my god, another one!
Oh my god.
Another one!
Okay, let's check...
Wait, oh, before...
Turn around?
Wait, I want to look at the paintings, too.
This wouldn't make my room look much better.
A medieval scene?
Quite the commentary this guy has.
A musical presentation.
This wouldn't make my room look much better.
What does that mean?
Um...
Oh...
What is this over here?
Wow.
These are solid iron.
Okay.
Spooky room.
All right.
What about this?
Oh, can't go in there.
What about here?
Solid.
Can I take this sheet too?
I'm not the least bit tired.
It's a bed.
But why is it like...
I can't light it.
I'd need wood.
It's kind of red.
Am I the only one seeing that?
It's too high up.
Anyway, it's barred.
Okay.
What are these?
Ah, books.
Too bad I wouldn't be able to understand a word of them.
Ah!
Oh, Halligan can't read!
Ah, books!
Oh!
You there!
You think that was a spy spying on me?
I think that was a spy.
suspicious they just get in my way they're just stones why would they get in my way why would they get in your way they just get in my way why oh my gosh this place looks very much like a workshop the music is okay hold on I don't want to go outside just yet let's finish inside maybe it's Ricky Martin okay there's this door here and then there's even more?
Oh my gosh, okay.
Ah!
Oh.
Okay, no, he wasn't a bad guy, guys.
He's fine.
It's only just days before execution.
I'm sure sitting on that would be considered a serious offense.
I don't think I ought to do it.
What?
I'd better leave that here.
Oh, the tonal whiplash.
Does this like make shit?
No, I was going to say shadows or something, but it doesn't seem to.
I actually have no idea.
Is this a...
Wait.
Oh, I messed up.
Wait, is that where it's supposed to go?
I sure hope so.
The abacus, that's what I was thinking of.
What's in here?
An old library.
Oh!
Filled with the typical smell of old leatherbound books.
Hi, Melanie.
I'll be back.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Back to spooky.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Why is the library...
Oh, my God, in here, too.
um why is the like the dining room a plate of tasty looking grape you never know it might come in handy what is that what did i just grab these are roots okay i don't need them there's flower in that tub okay i got some roots i think it's a calendar maybe that doesn't look particularly tasty don't be rude looks like blood whoa wait what's here I'd better leave it where it is why that looks revolting take it take it that looks revolting take it take it all steal I'll take it with me oh yeah take it with you it's too heavy for me take it this music is Taking me out.
I'm gonna...
Oh.
Not very easy to handle.
I'd better leave them here.
They are spears.
No, I'm trying to talk to the man!
A dining tea.
It's big.
That's a lot of crockery.
What does...
So we don't... Oh.
What is this?
uh oh is does that open a window to the other room oh to here so if i were to maybe like make something and then put it here that guy would eat it you know i'm assuming if i made him like a poison storage jugs why should i take jugs with me when i haven't got
man doesn't want jugs
oh my gosh this place is oh what do you want I take it your sesterner am I right and you were the man who came all the way here just to let me kill it sounds like a voice changer is the little bit of life I've granted you too much for you what B-Tuber why are you not using your real voice.
Virtuber, turn it.
This is just, that's just a guy with a voice changer.
Come to offer you a deal.
Wait a second.
Wait, I can't, I can't leave.
No, I wanted to save.
Oh gosh, I should have saved.
What are you planning to do to us?
When the great day has come and the ritual has been perfected, your lives will end.
Why don't you just kill us right now?
be allowed to live for a few more days my brother maglore spoke up for you and i was incapable of refusing him his wish i have such a very soft heart what did maglore say he suggested making you our witnesses the first witnesses of our unlimited power you will watch your miserable world come You,
eternal empire, arise from the ashes.
And then you will die.
A great honor will be bestowed upon you.
You will be the last sacrifices of the old world.
You're mad, completely insane.
Wait, I like him.
Wait, can I leave, please?
I want to offer him a deal, but I want to save first.
I've come to offer you a deal.
A deal?
You are offering me a deal?
You overrate your importance.
I will not do deals with you.
Dang.
I know something that you can't know.
What might that be?
I won't tell you until you give me your word that you will let me and my friend go.
What?
that I came from the future I know what happens to you guys there is nothing you can know there is nothing you can bargain I literally came from the future I will not enter into any deal with a useless creature like you I will grind you underfoot if it pleases me to do so that is all you may expect from me now get out of my sight oh I know something you do do me into 22 okay Okay,
good.
Well, we've done a lot of exploring.
It would really suck to accidentally crash the game.
Oh, okay.
What are these, marbles on the ground?
Someone's losing their marbles.
Can I take your blanket?
A druid's bed.
Huh.
It's a druid's bed.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
It's locked.
Dang it.
Bad luck.
A crate.
Dude's talking like a MF Doom sample.
This place is nonsensical.
Do these guys, like, not vacuum?
Take it.
A basket?
That's empty.
I like when the music is spooky.
It really sets the tone.
And then it's...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Gosh.
It wraps around.
Okay.
all right so we can go talk to Melanie what if I go back in there we can go talk to Melanie and we can go outside those are our two options now what you want oh are you so eager to die your death will come soon enough now get out one moment please just one short moment may I ask you one more question you do not need to ask questions it would be a waste of time answering you you would not understand the answers anyway i'll chance that you must think you're very clever just like all fools you will soon understand just how pointless each of your actions sentences and thoughts have you seen very soon now my power will be multiplied and i will continue to exist within it it will make me immortal and you will be no more than a pile of dust that the wind will carry out to sea.
Um.
What was I getting?
Oh, it's like in Colombo when the person that did it gets really upset by Colombo just being an annoying little guy.
And that's what we're doing here.
I've heard your order is facing its downfall.
that from whom from a fool like yourself our order is not facing its downfall but a great new beginning even if some of my brothers disliked the idea or did you think I did not know of the ridiculous conspiracy that some of my misguided brothers have set up they have told you of it haven't they I do not expect you to betray them but they are greatly mistaken where their abilities and they underestimate me.
I will soon find out which of my brothers are betraying me.
And I will destroy them without even lifting a finger.
The path I have determined cannot be altered.
Our fate is sealed.
Now get out of my sight.
You bore me.
You don't even let me get a...
I bore you because you don't let me get a sentence in.
Um, okay.
This one was the kitchen.
Okay, here is where Melanie is.
Ready for music?
It sounds like Sims shopping music or something.
Hello, Melanie.
How's it going?
I found a few more chronicles.
One of them describes all the details of the heathen practices in this region.
The monks kept an eye on them because the heathens were their competition, you might say.
What were these heathen practices?
think i ought to tell you you wouldn't be too pleased oh right i get it thanks for being so considerate i think i've heard enough stories of cannibalism to last me a few years thank you very much how are you getting on i need a bit more time the monastery is rather large and it's hard not to get lost also i keep finding some druid or other following me around we don't have much time brent what can i do i haven't found the room with the crystal ball yet let alone a way out of here it's probably behind that spooky room we found anything about the druids why is the music so like it's so sad it's so heartfelt it's making me feel things have you found anything about the druids in these books nothing we didn't already know it talks a lot about the transformation of the four elements Mr. Blake told you all about that,
didn't he?
Yes, that's right.
You've got to hand it to him.
He'd done his homework all right.
I've found everything he said about the four elements in the Christian monk's original texts.
I don't see how the elements are going to be of any help to us.
Anything can be useful, Brent.
I just thought I'd mention it.
Do you remember what Blake told you?
Yeah.
Peeping music.
Oh.
Remind me.
Now what was it?
The Druids believed that the four elements were the stuff that made up the world.
I might have stopped listening to Mr. Blake.
The three basic elements.
Fire's only purpose was to transfer one element into the state of another.
Okay.
Which means?
Fire will turn solids or liquids into gas.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Fire can turn a gas into a liquid.
Take a combination of oxygen and hydrogen, for instance.
Fire stands for transformation.
The transfer of material into a new state.
It's not that difficult, is it?
Oh.
Could I ask you something personal?
Melanie, could I ask you something personal?
Do you really think this is the right time?
No, probably not.
But who knows if I'll ever get another chance to ask you.
Well, what is it?
I'm curious.
Oh, no.
No, we're going to do...
No, never mind.
Forget it.
I'm so dark and mysterious.
If we ever get out of here alive...
No way.
Wait.
Which one do I do?
No, you wouldn't.
Do we play hard to get or do we play pathetic?
Riz her?
If we ever get out of here alive...
Yes.
Would you...
I mean, could you ever bring yourself to...
The cinema.
Go to Al's Pizza Palace for a pizza with you?
Yes, I think I'd like that.
Hey, how did you guess?
Do you know Al's Pizza Palace?
I've never been there, Brent.
But when I went to Scotland Yard to look for you, I took a look at your office.
I couldn't miss the boxes.
No.
Oh, I see.
A bit untidy in there, isn't it?
You could say that.
Yes.
I should try and tidy up in there sometime.
But you'd come with me?
I told you, yes.
Right.
It's a deal.
I'll remind you about it.
Okay, Brent.
I'm looking forward to it.
But it might be an idea if we try to get out of here alive first.
What do you think?
Of course.
I'm sure we will.
Oh, my God.
Okay, Melanie.
I'll go on looking.
Good luck.
It worked.
We're gonna go get Alice Pizza Palace with Melody!
Oh, I can't believe she saw...
She saw...
Oh, I forgot about the music.
She saw our mess of an office and still agreed.
Do you think she knows that I think it's a date?
Do you think she knows that?
I'm thinking it's a date.
I'll have to go a bit closer to do anything there.
Oh, here we go.
though a water oh no making Melanie pay is 275 pounds yeah I don't think they want me back there Melanie salad salad I hate salad I hate Salad.
Sorry, it totally caught me off guard!
The inner courtyard is bigger than I thought.
Oh my god!
I hate salad.
Salad.
Simple wooden buckets.
They're all empty.
Oh gosh, this game is so something.
These could be the stables.
What a special game.
Of some melons.
I hate melons.
that's just not my style what does that even mean it's a pitchfork what do you what do you mean it's not your style oh my gosh i feel like i'm missing so much oh anyone in there i don't have a key the door's bolted not a chance okay what's what is oh is this like the water reservoir for the garden okay i'm guessing i don't see anything unusual down there okay uh
it's not it's like a whole head of cabbage or lettuce or whatever and he's like i hate salad what's this there's a definite smell of stables here uh
whole head of salad yeah halogen is he's our he's our he's our guy he's our guy okay after this though I'm getting so overwhelmed with how much is around here I might have to consult the walkthrough because I'm like what this is not the music I would have expected for the blacksmith I don't think my help is required an interesting construction I don't know thing about being a blacksmith very impressive that anvil okay let's talk to him hello good day friend good day friend how are you how should i be every day i work my fingers to the bone i get bad food bad treatment how would you be
is there anything i can do is there anything i can do for you you look at you a weakling like you i bet you couldn't even the hammer I used to have an apprentice who looked a lot like you didn't stay long though to add for him all right if you don't want my help you can help me by not standing around in my way if I don't get my work pieces finished by tomorrow I'd be punished badly no I wouldn't let them I wouldn't let them touch a pretty hair on your
head what exactly do you do here anyway I worked forge for my masters isn't that obvious pipes weapons locks keys a lot not right now of course since the fire's gone out are you forging weapons for the war you mean the war against the danes no no wars come and go year after year my masters don't get involved they are a secret i see you don't seem to like your masters much not like him i Years and years I've spent slaving away in this smithy and my children are starving anyway Once I dared to go to Sir Stan's room ask for more money.
Halligan definitely gets sardines What did they do to you ten lashes of the whip?
My bare back.
Oh my god I've lied down for three weeks.
I've given up asking questions since then.
I can't hear you over the whimsical music
but they are powerful and cruel I have to finish my work by tomorrow or else I'll be punished in some horrible way tell me about the druids I don't know much about them anyway I'm not allowed to tell you anything ah that's interesting look stranger I don't know about you but I'm quite attached to my head I don't fancy being slaughtered because you're so nosy oh my goodness oh my goodness then why is it so urgent why is your work so urgent i don't really know myself why they need this stuff so quickly is it for the ritual helping to prepare some big ceremony affairs anyway they keep strengthening their fortifications to make it so he can't do his job have you noticed anything unusual around here lately unusual no not really except that it's extremely quiet in the monastery oh hang on yeah yeah there was I heard children crying two days ago.
It was after dark.
I couldn't see much, but I think the crying was coming from one of those private rooms.
Did it sound like babies crying?
Yeah, it did.
Just like that.
Interesting.
Did you notice anything else?
No.
No, nothing.
Why do you ask?
Just asking.
A ceremony.
A ceremony?
Yeah.
of some sort.
Don't ask me what it's all about.
I don't know anything about their heathen religions.
I was brought up a Christian.
There's hardly any Druids left in Britain these days anyway.
Except here.
Except here is all of them.
I already asked about anything unusual, so...
I'll have a look around if you don't mind.
All right.
Go ahead.
So...
Do we want to help him or do we want to sabotage them?
Oh, look at this.
Is this blood?
I don't have anything that I need to die.
Looks like a tub of dye.
They're too far away.
I don't want to get into trouble.
Uh-huh.
I... Oh!
Oh, yes.
This looks familiar.
It's the symbol.
I wonder what this symbol stands for.
It's... it's... it's the campfire!
Okay, how do I get out of here, actually?
Uh, which, oh, this way.
Let's continue searching around.
We were going this way.
These must be the stores.
There's a lot of stuff here.
The stores.
Oh, what did I just take?
Oh, just some wood.
A little piece of wood.
We're just gonna take that and put it in my pocket for...
Unknown reason.
Other things he's...
like nah this cramps my style they're just empty crates but no this little piece of wood i like it they are just empty crates well you could bring it back and be like look at this this is wood from from thousands of years ago and it looks brand new and they'd be like oh you got it you're right looks a bit too creepy for my liking i think i'll steer clear of the shed but it could have things that we need to know about in there they are just empty Okay,
stupid.
This guy.
Just a box.
Yeah, what if we have our back turned and it starts moving around?
Um, so, uh, like I said earlier, I'm going to consult the walkthrough because we've just been introduced to at least 20 rooms.
So, um, yeah, wait a second.
In the candle room.
pixel hunting get some candles okay so we missed candles I got the roots in the black bucket goodness gracious he wants to do it is this a piece of wood in your pocket no what was a candle room there was a candle room
wait I'm gonna do a new save sorry just in case for whatever reason
Candle room.
Will you be streaming Silent Hill?
Yeah, tomorrow.
Is this a candle room?
This room has candles.
Wait, no, this is your room.
Just kidding.
This was where I came from.
What was the candle room?
Not candle room.
I don't think that's a candle room.
I don't think this is the candle room.
This is probably the blue room.
I think.
Candle room.
What room was this?
Wait, what's this one?
Is it?
Oh, oh, we didn't even go in here.
No one will notice they're missing.
No wonder I didn't know what a candle room was.
Very efficient weapons.
of candles in here.
Good grief.
Why is that an issue?
There must be hundreds of candles in here.
Okay, so we got candles and we've got...
Okay, candles and the wood.
Outside near the crops is where we need to go.
Okay.
Minto.
That's me!
That's me.
That's my name.
Don't wear it.
How did I miss that room?
huh he hates candles my man doesn't like any all right sorry that i'm like gonna be kind of walk through stalking a little bit um like i said there's just so much okay so it says i need to put the roots somewhere right let's use this herb then i don't think that's how you use this I don't
think that's what continue down this path the large stone chasm okay oh there was a lever over here okay I thought so so over here we got a pixel hunt a little bit run run run what is bro cooking I'm not quite sure I not quite sure so there's a lever I don't see anything unusual down there is that it no I don't know what to look wait maybe hold on
on the pipe oh there it is oh my gosh it's teeny tiny ah yes a lever it works the water's flowing now are starve them?
Worms.
What?
It's a druid's biggest weakness.
I'd better turn it off again.
Wait, what?
Are they poisonous worms?
Are we gonna make poison worm soup?
And they will all Um, what?
Oh,
grab those worms.
Huh.
Why did I get those?
Okay, okay.
I've...
Oh, I...
Okay.
Remember, we saw that bird's nest.
The bird might want worms.
Apparently the bird is up here.
But how do I...
Wait, okay, hold on.
Use the worms on the bird's nest.
But they're so far up.
Right click on the right side of the roof.
Wait, maybe I'm from this side.
Aha!
There's a bird's nest up on the chimney.
I'll never be able to reach it from here of the worms i can think of better ways of using the worms i can't what are you talking about i can think of better ways of using the worms here's the worms on the roof away from the nest oh here i can think of better ways of using the worms um if you think a guy is fine you're trying to cram weeks of fun into a few streams after all so true maybe this side
the walkthrough says use the worms click the right hand side of the roof use worms on the roof away from the nest so the birds has to leave the nest huh
it did say though that I have to exhaust all the dialogue with this guy maybe I didn't I'd like to ask you a few more things concerning our talk well keep it short um it's pretty hazy in here it's pretty smoky in here do you know that of course i know a damn fire keeps going out ever seen a smith who could work without the fire what's the matter does the rain get in oh what do i know oh maybe the birds are always problems with the fire in here nothing works but everything's supposed to be finished the bird's nest is ruining the fire that's why scotland yard's not Scotland yard where's that and Scotland no no let's just say it's a place it takes a long time to get to mmm all I know is the settlements on the other side of the river and I curse the day I left them to come here I should have stayed in the village okay I'd be better off in London what village what village east of the river I was born there and I lived there until I came here asking for work that was a big mistake I thought
I could earn some money here to feed my family what happened I became a slave to those druids
you think you'll be able to get me I think you might be able to help me get out of here I'd have to be pretty stupid to try that I had to pledge loyalty to Sirsten when I came here.
Sirsten!
That guy's silly.
Come and go.
Okay.
I see.
Oh well, looks like there's nothing I can do for you or that you can do for me.
I'm really sorry, stranger.
Aww.
I have enough problems here, isn't it?
He's a good guy, maybe.
I really can't do with any more.
I think he's good.
Okay.
I'll have a look around if you don't mind.
All right.
Go ahead.
All right, let me try one more time and see if there's anything else.
ask you a few more things concerning our talk well keep it short then what did i ask oh what exactly do you do here anyway i worked the forge for my masters isn't that obvious pipes weapons rocks keys a lot not right now of course since the maybe he'll like me and he'll make me weapons for the war you mean the war against the danes a key or something you know wars come and go My masters don't get involved.
They are a secretive lot.
Okay, I think we talked to him here.
Okay, so let's leave.
Okay, maybe now.
Maybe now.
There's a bird's nest up on the chimney.
I'll never be able to reach it from here.
Well, how do I get it then?
Actually.
Hmm.
Oh, there was an arrow up.
There was.
Wait, there was.
Can you climb so...
Oh, you're right.
Unless...
Oh, I thought that went inside.
Oh, you're right.
We could talk to the bird.
Well, are you quite comfortable?
It's a bird.
A crow, I think.
Doop, doop, doop, doop, doop.
okay we're he moves away and we destroy his nest and all of his life's work and all of his babies and everything
sorry it had to be done sorry so sorry yay yay yay okay
it works now aren't you so happy i've cleared the chimney that ought to solve your problem with the fire the chimney yes there was a crow's nest on it i took it down that's all oh yeah great stranger you just saved my neck you better get back to work now and quickly i must hurry and then you'll help me thank you my friend okay thank you my friend i'll take a look around all right please yourself see you later stranger in front of you no sir all right now apparently we have to go to a room with a fire place that was lit,
which I vaguely remember.
I think it was, like, over here.
Now we check every room.
It was that here.
Maybe going the wrong way.
I could be.
Oh, this place is such a maze.
Yeah, it was one of the Druid's rooms, yeah.
But the fire was lit, and I do remember it.
I just don't remember where.
I think that's...
What's his name?
Sussie's room.
Oh, oh, okay.
So, sorry.
Walk through.
Explain to me again.
Uh, use the iron bucket on the fire and place the candles in.
Okay.
I can do that.
You're not sorry for committing crimes.
Right.
Now the crucibles in the fireplace.
yes and then we melt our candlesticks oh it looks like boobs again the candles have melted now I've got a block of wax ominous wax I'm sorry guys I know that I'm like just going through the walkthrough, but
I have to go back to his office, but it wouldn't let me pixel hunt.
The guy, uh, Sissy, Sussy, Sissy, Sirsten, S-Sister?
Have you not been listening to me?
Get out!
I'd like to watch you.
I'd like to stay and watch you.
I understand.
You wish to see for your what lies in store for you.
I can't get over his voice.
Many doomed men are fascinated by their executioners.
Man's curiosity is greater than his fear.
Curiosity brought you here and curiosity will kill you.
Then you don't mind?
Ha ha ha ha.
Be my guest if it abuses you.
Watch me preparing for your final hour.
I love this guy.
As long as you do not touch any I can't even know you're here.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
You appreciate it.
You are a pathetic creature.
Ah, he called me.
He clocked me so fast.
Minto 24.
Okay, so what is this?
I noticed this while he was talking.
This secret compartment is empty.
Wait.
Oh, we do still have the amulet.
No.
What?
Is this the wax?
A block of candle wax.
Just got to stick that in there.
Oh, okay.
I use this wood in here.
Oh, I can take it back out if I want to.
No, we put that in there.
Interesting.
What's your paintings, mister?
This should remain here.
Wait!
This was in this was in their house too.
Wait, so was this one, but I don't recognize this one Might be the guy on the box Oh wait, no this one wait.
They kept all these images all these paintings Until modern time Wow That's crazy Okay, so apparently now we got to go talk to our favorite Malgam
Mark, that guy.
His room was, uh, this one?
Magmar, yeah.
Didn't I tell you not to speak to me?
Sorry.
It'll only take a minute.
It'll only take a moment.
What is it?
Have you found the room that harbors the crystal ball?
Not yet.
I have found...
No, of course not.
If you don't know where it is, how should I?
find out until then do not put us in jeopardy no okay bye very well see you later well didn't i tell you not to speak to me okay we have to tell him about something oh ask him to get you undisturbed access to sirs sirsden i saw sirsden did you make a try yeah he said he will have us killed that's what oh by the way i also heard that it was actually your idea to have us executed on the day of the ritual.
Do not believe his lies.
I suggested nothing of the sword.
Don't believe Sir Sten's lies.
How do I know you're not in this with him?
There is no cause for you to doubt my words.
He could be one of the spies!
Who are the other conspirators?
Won't you introduce me to them?
Are you out of your mind?
How can you speak so openly here?
Do you want to betray us?
Sir Sten's spies are everywhere.
You are one of them!
Maybe.
I must leave at once.
They will have heard.
us.
But I'm sure it will be a great help to me to know who's a friend around here and who isn't.
Just look upon everyone as your enemy.
That is the safest way.
I don't find that thought very comforting.
I will not betray my brothers to you.
Why not?
If you fail, it will be better that you do not know their names.
Who says you're a friend anyway?
Yeah, exactly.
I can do no more than give you my word.
I don't know whether to believe you or not.
Be honest.
I don't know whether to believe lying to you who knows maybe you're just keeping me here so that i won't be alive in 1 000 years time so sinclair can just perform this ritual without anybody wait who will work at this at the police station you must make up your own mind whether or not to trust me if i'm not there do i have any choice in the matter none of us who will set the bush on fire okay we have to ask him to well see you later somehow get me access to his didn't i tell you not to speak to me Oh,
here it is.
I need undisturbed access.
I need undisturbed access to one of the rooms in the monastery.
Hmm.
Which room?
Who will steal Lowry's scissors?
Serstan's room.
Is that possible?
Out of the question.
Whenever Serstan leaves his room, he locks the door and never lets the key out of his sight.
I see.
That settles that, then, doesn't it?
Or is there some way he could be lured away?
him out of his room on some pretext just long enough for me to take a look around undisturbed the way he like oh pretty please pretty please if i go on my tippy toes okay wait wait did he do it
are we getting in there hold on i'm gonna save ringto 25.
Is he gone?
Maglore did it.
Now I can take a good look around in peace.
Oh, the fire is on his desk.
Serston's writing desk.
This is here again.
Ah!
What is this?
I don't feel I should be doing this.
I do.
If I push that stone in there, I'll never get it out again.
And I'll never get the casket back in.
Well, um, what do you want to do with it?
Wow, what a lovely view.
I like the view.
You're my best view.
This is a pretty jagged stretch of the coastline.
Maybe actually it would be good to have the brick.
We could throw it at his head.
Oh.
He's bound to notice at once that the key's missing.
What the key?
How do I open this?
Oh, wait.
Here?
It would have surprised me if it worked like that how do i open it where whoa he watched me gather worms maybe wow it's sparkling it's too far away could i throw it into here that doesn't work dang it can i i thought it would throw it into the hay and he would have noticed that it was in there because hay is for horses not for not for for little chests beautiful view bottom right
got any wax could we stick it in there now a block of candle wax wait what about this one wait I can't see any connection there you but it's a there's a key and a key with and with a thing that needs a key okay what Wait!
What?
Could I not put it in here?
No way.
Why not?
A block of candle wax.
That doesn't work.
Why is it in a no way?
We could get the imprint of the key, right?
Use the worms!
Wait!
Take it out, get the...
Place it on the small table.
Oh, so I have to put it here to work on it.
Oh, okay, okay.
Now we can mess with it.
Aha, there's the key.
It's just open?
It'll be too dangerous to take them with me.
I couldn't make head or tail of them anyway.
Okay.
These are scrolls.
Sirstan seems to be working on documents.
Okay, so now we can use the key and this.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Do I put it all back, though?
What about...
first now there's an imprint of the key in the wax block okay good now we put it back would have surprised me if it had worked like that we don't that's the key from sir stan's casket wait did we not put it back or
because he's gonna notice it's missing
huh but we need to put it back right that won't get me there's no point in that yeah i want to take this to the to the blacksmith, but I think we need to put it back, no?
I can't.
Thank you so much for membership.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for 20 gifts.
Thank you.
Oh, I gotta put it back on the stool and then put it back in and then put it back in.
Okay.
Gosh.
Order of operations.
Order of operations, everybody.
Okay.
All right.
There we go.
And then back in.
Into the hole it goes.
No?
Uh.
Hmm?
But.
Maybe it's pixel perfect?
Did I miss something?
Oh, do I have to do it like this?
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
now we may leave somehow I don't think I put everything back as I found it no I think we did wait what do you mean what did I miss place what did I miss place maybe I have to take um the wood out I don't feel I should be doing this maybe I I need to do this.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
No evidence left at all.
The perfect crime.
Alligan gets away with it again!
And then we gotta go outside.
Which, which, which way was that?
Which, which way?
Okay, now to...
The blacksmith.
She's a master of stealth.
Hello, sir.
Can you help me with this?
I need your help.
Could you take a look at this?
That's the impression of a key.
So what?
I've helped you.
Now I'm asking you to help me.
Make a key like this one.
It'll take you two seconds.
What?
Impossible.
Sorry, stranger.
Why not?
I'll tell you.
They'd kill us both.
You owe me something.
Yeah, you owe me.
If it hadn't been for me, they'd have punished you tomorrow anyway.
You said so yourself.
Oh, God help me.
I must be going crazy.
All right.
Crazy in love for me, huh?
I'll make you a key.
It'll take a while, though.
No problem.
I'll come back later to pick it up.
Yeah.
Oh, there he goes.
He's working on it.
And I'm just shuffling along.
I'm just shuffling around behind him.
Nice, nice, nice.
Go to the throne room.
Look at the beads without touching them.
I touched them, though.
Not sure how I feel about Halegan's historical crime spree.
I have this.
This guy is probably causing all sorts of time paradoxes, but that's fine.
was this the throne room whimsical music incoming
oh good god Brent you made me just say hello sorry you were so sorry you were so wrapped up in your books yes this one's really interesting yeah it's hard to make out though it deals with transformation rituals have you ever heard of a magical top no magical tops set objects in motion every druid carries one round she found the yaoi fanfic what's it good for it's a symbol of what of the earth's rotation and the cycle of the elements the druids believe that all natural phenomena are based on a transformation cycle fire transforms the elements the magical top is a symbol of this cycle the cycle of life you see sounds interesting yes i have to go on revealing.
I may even find a clue as to how Sirstan plans to perform his ritual.
Could you leave me for a while, please?
Certainly.
I'll come back later.
The magical top is part of the circle of life, you guys.
And this very...
She's talking about Beyblades.
Yeah, it's very revealing.
in this...
in this book!
Ye old dojin Shi!
Go to the creepy dimly lit inner sanctum.
Oh wait, the key should have the key now.
Okay, cool.
I was like, what's the creepy room?
I, of course we know.
We know the creepy room.
Ye old dojin Shi.
Yes.
right your key that was so fast I didn't give you this key of course not friend if you're cart with this it's your problem not mine yes yes all right thank you give it to me sure you won't change your mind this could kill you you know I I'll be alright no I'll be alright he sounds so cool oh well don't say I didn't warn you here you go take care of yourself thank you We have to have it to progress the story.
Alright, I will.
Thanks a lot.
Let's save game.
Into 26.
Oh my gosh.
I'm getting so old.
Alright, let's go to the creepy room, the creepy room.
We gotta make it to the creepy room.
This way might be faster.
Aging rapidly.
here we go the creepy room all right here we go actually hold on let's just save in here
yes guys when is windows 10 not good anymore i'm like holding off until the last day i don't want windows 11
isn't it like october something wait i need two keys
kidding horror game logic does not apply here
no no sense of like caution at all
what oh my goodness is this a maze follow the guide here oh oh Okay, I'm going back, I'm going back.
Oh,
uh-oh.
The guide does not work.
Oh, shoot.
Guys, I already messed up.
Okay, hold on.
We'll reload.
We'll reload the game.
Oh, no.
Okay.
I learned my lesson.
It's so fine.
It's fine because we get to see this cutscene again.
I can't believe that going back does not oh my gosh that does seem miserable okay we saved ourselves a headache for sure
oh okay the guide here
it is recommended you save here because if you get the order muddled up you can load fresh here all right go through the doorways in the correct order It is the right door.
Unless they mean Halligan's right.
Probably not, right?
And then we go middle.
Okay.
And then we go furthest right.
Imagine if everyone agreed to not make a guide for this part.
Evil.
Then we go right again.
Okay.
Weeks of fun!
Okay, now we backtrack.
He should say, oh no.
Oh, oh, this looks like it might prove a little difficult.
Furthest left.
Weeks of fun!
Backtrack.
Oh, this is...
This is way too long.
I'm sorry.
What the hell?
Oh my god.
Okay, middle.
Furthest left.
This is so evil.
This is actually... This is so evil.
And then in the very end...
What do you think, you guys?
What do you think we do?
You think you go left or right?
No, no.
You go... You backtrack.
What the actual hell?
We did it!
Weeks of fun.
Weeks of fun!
Oh, you can...
Okay, at the bottom of...
Okay.
Let's just, uh...
Let's go.
Let's go explore ourselves.
Wow.
it was worth coming here I don't think he'd be so impressed
a young tree a branch a sapling a fully grown tree an old tree I think this is an hourglass yes so the hourglass takes you to the past or the present or the future impressive yeah wait
it says close the doors behind you got to close the doors impressive oh here we go
oh it's freaky
It's another maze!
Imagine?
Sometimes just scampers around so much.
Oh no.
I'm taking a photo of this.
Okay, I took a picture.
Get ready to par, God.
Okay.
So that's for the big tree.
And the small tree.
Oh no!
It's all broke.
I took another picture.
But it might be messed up.
Well, they seem pretty in place still.
Maybe.
And now let's go ponder the orb.
One you need a photo of was the one you played with upstairs.
No?
Wait, really?
That shouldn't be the case.
Okay.
I'm pondering the order.
Wow.
Stonehenge!
That was Stonehenge.
Completely destroyed.
Yeah, how bizarre.
Okay.
Hold on.
Wait, what?
the guide is telling me the answer but I don't quite understand do I just solve this here oh
I do wait oh my gosh wait so it's not this puzzle oh it's not this one that I needed to take a picture of it was the one upstairs that is the thing that I'm copying are you kidding me right now I had already messed it up.
Well, it's a good thing.
How was I supposed to know?
How are you today, Vinto?
I'm great.
How are you?
Thank you so much for the super chat.
How was I supposed to know?
I just started playing with the balls.
Oh, man.
Wait, this should be it.
Okay, this should be it.
And now...
Point and clicks be like those sometimes.
Literally soft locked me in.
The stick.
What was that?
It's absolutely diabolical they let you play.
Why?
It's diabolical they let you play with the one upstairs because it should just be able to be left alone.
All right.
Guys, I think we're nearing the end because we're on part four of the walkthrough.
Oh my gosh.
That's the final part.
I think we're nearing the end.
It's already been almost three hours.
I can't believe this.
I'm so into this game.
We must go tell me.
How do we get home?
Easy!
Okay, great.
And we're just gonna leave the doors open.
I wonder actually how long this would take me without a walkthrough.
And without you guys helping.
Oh, he's not here.
My co-workers came to work sick earlier this week.
I've been feeling worse all day.
No!
Road!
I'm so sorry.
Aw, get well soon!
Oh, for many people using...
Oh, for people using this walkthrough out of order, this part starts immediately after have you looked into the crystal ball.
Okay, yeah, I have parts 1, 2, 3?
You may want to glance over parts 1, 2, and 3 and make sure you have the underlying items from those parts.
I sure hope so.
I don't think I can go back to parts 1 and 2.
I think we would be really really messed up then I think we're okay though go to my chamber okay Maglar's in here so we're not going on a wild goose chase looking in every room for this guy hello oh what maglo there you are I have been looking for you everywhere what a strut I figured it in the room where the crystal ball is hidden really is a calendar it works just like the one in the assembly chamber but with an additional day and night cycle and an hour schedule i entered the time of the ritual we figured that out how and sestan appeared in the crystal what what was he doing he was holding a staff decorated with runes which suddenly began to glow then he picked up a golden sickle a staff he used a bewitched staff to summon the power if we find that staff Yeah,
we do all of that.
Where could he be keeping it?
I've searched the whole monastery and found nothing.
The temples!
How do we get there?
I haven't seen any exit.
The Christian monks built this monastery in such a way that it is only accessible through a secret tunnel.
Oh, that's how we got here.
Serston uses that to his advantage, as it allows him to control us.
Anyone wishing to leave the monastery is blindfolded and guided by Serston himself.
Nobody can leave here without Serston.
Where are they?
Bring them to me!
Did you hear that?
Hear what?
Out there.
I think I heard Serstan's voice.
He's looking for us.
Damn it.
That's all we need.
Lock the door.
And then let's get the hell out of here.
Okay.
Uh...
Maybe here?
Um...
Hmm.
Nothing's happening.
Yeah, no...
No kidding.
Like, maybe...
What?
I figured it'd be...
When we got this sheet, I was like, maybe it's so that we can, like, create a little rope to drop down, but I guess not.
I don't want that.
Oh, we don't?
Okay.
Unless we do it like this.
No.
How do we get out of here?
How do we get out now?
I don't know.
Open up, traitors.
The door won't hold him up for very long.
Okay.
Uh, hold on.
Hold on.
Take the sheet from the bed and use it on the candle.
What candle?
Oh, this?
Are you...
Why?
What?
Hi, Mint.
Hi.
Huh?
No?
I should think up something else.
Wait.
Huh?
Just wait and see.
That...
It won't work like that.
It's at the left window.
But I don't.
Maybe it's my other left.
You know?
Uh...
Yes.
Maybe it's a pixel perfect thing.
Um, look out the window on the left and use the sheet on it.
On what?
I'd rather think about it again.
What?
The chain?
It won't work like that.
Now there's a hole in the sheet.
Why did you do that?
Oh!
Right, let's get out of here.
What?
Oh my gosh, it was pixel perfect.
Parachute?
Huh?
Wait, this will not hold to people.
What?
Wait!
We will fall to our death.
Not with our parachute.
We've got no alternative but to jump.
Now hold on.
What?
Fireball!
Oh my gosh!
What is it?
It's homing!
Phew, that was close.
Um, are we not gonna talk about Maglord?
Oh, no, no, no, 28.
Are we just not gonna talk about...
of human shield, Maglore.
Let's go get him.
Let's go get our buddy.
Maglore, Maglore!
Where are you?
Can you hear me?
That was close for me.
Wait, there he is.
Maglore, are you hurt?
Are you hurt?
That's the first thing you ask?
He hit me in the back.
You are on your own.
Now.
don't talk nonsense you won't die tell me how I can help you you are wasting your time don't act the hero what do I have to do there's mistletoe in the forest you want to kiss could try you want me to kiss it make it feel better severe injuries go and look for it what mistletoe what does that look like You will recognize it.
Okay, okay.
Why doesn't he know?
Don't give up.
I'll be back in a second.
How does he know I'll recognize it?
Okay, don't give up.
Don't give up.
We're going to get the mistletoe for you.
Is this it?
I won't touch them with my bare hands.
I still have gloves.
What if we give him poison ivy instead?
What about Melanie?
Oh!
Don't give up.
I'll be back in a second.
I got you!
Your mistletoe!
The healing mistletoe.
Uh...
It's pixel perfect.
I had it there, just.
I've got the mistletoe.
What do I have to do now?
Maglore?
Maglore!
Damn it!
Uh...
Maglore!
Do you...
You need mistletoe?
How is that right above us?
Wait, is he dead?
Oh.
Oh, am I taking...
You won't recognize it.
I took a...
I took the power top!
Wait, what was it called?
That's a top.
It's
a magical top.
We got it.
Okay, sorry, I know I'm safe scubbing a little bit, but I don't want to...
I thought I was pretty fast with that mistletoe.
I'm not gonna lie.
It's fast with getting that, I think.
What is this, anyway?
Okay, no description.
Who are we...
Wait, do we keep the mistletoe for, like, kissing Melanie later, you think?
You think that's what we're gonna do with her?
You think so?
Be like it, Melanie.
Merry Christmas.
Whoa, why is there a staircase behind here?
I can't open this.
Open what?
I can see strange rooms behind these walls.
Yeah, cool.
The nail!
Finally, we can scratch it!
Whoa, he actually has nothing to say.
A strange table.
It scratches from the top.
I am the magical top.
Bayblade let her rip.
Whoa.
So Melanie, before asking her to pay the tab.
Take that.
Okay, just kidding.
Okay.
Whoa!
Um, I don't think this room was worth it.
Oh, oops.
What is this?
Ah, they look like switches.
Nope, it doesn't work anymore.
Am I trying to get them all in?
Nope.
This switch is broken.
It doesn't work anymore.
Oh, it's...
Wait.
Okay.
I...
But is it supposed to be all...
All...
In or all...
Ow!
Maybe it's supposed to be like alternating.
Wait, that one...
Oh, because it'll be up and up in.
Oh.
Nope.
It doesn't work anymore.
nope it doesn't work nope it doesn't work anymore he pisses me off oh
it just says click the middle one and then go back in okay so this also switches things around interesting oh what is this what is that that's a flint oh and steel
Flint and steel.
Chicken Jackie.
Soup!
Okay, I got a ladle.
A ladle.
Yeah.
Alright.
Enter the spinning chamber again and again.
Go up the stairs and get this shovel.
Okay, we gotta keep going around and around, baby.
Nothing here.
Oh, what is this?
A bagpipe?
I can't take it.
There seems to be some kind of invisible barrier over the bowl.
Oh my gosh!
Well, what's up here?
Oh, this is the air!
Okay.
Alright.
Maybe I can take it now.
I can't take it.
Okay.
And then...
Hold on, I'm just glancing at the...
Okay, we just got to keep getting the little altar items.
I'm getting dizzy.
Wait, is this my top still here?
Okay, I'll take it still.
Uh, we gotta get...
We gotta keep going through, I guess.
What is this one?
Oh, this is the water.
For some reason I'm not able to get at it.
There seems to be some kind of invisible barrier.
over the bowl okay we just got to keep going in circles this is really bizarre what this game bizarre that's a flint oh we got another flint
okay yeah use the ladle use oh i was too late a room with nothing
oh dirt for some reason i can't take any soil that won't get me any further wait this i gotta go back and get the ladle use the ladle okay so we got some dirt oh okay okay now we can get the air too okay awesome the poop scoop it's like my cat's litter box this should the middle one should be fine we just have to go back in order what we before.
Okay, this is fire.
Nothing.
Okay, keep going.
Keep going.
We grab air.
Wait.
We grab the air.
Nice.
And then back.
And then we get the water.
Oh my gosh, I'm going to have to go all the way through this again.
Oh my gosh, okay.
The water.
Oh, I did that again.
And bring back the ancient air to present times.
Okay.
Use the shovel on the soil.
Enter the...
Use the...
Okay.
Now we can...
Go back to the chamber.
Should be able to exit.
Hopefully we can exit soon.
Oh my gosh.
What the?
Oh, I didn't press that.
Okay.
Oh my god.
When does it end?
Let me out of this hellhole!
Oh, we're out!
Okay, we can leave now.
Oh, thank goodness.
No, no, okay, good, good.
All right.
First of all, hold on.
We save.
Mito 29.
I'm about to hit the big three-oh.
I hope this game reveals the mystery of why the druids bothered with all this complicated nonsense.
It's because only they would understand.
Wait, what is this?
As a megalith.
A megalith.
Only they would understand, and then...
No one else would be able to do their rituals.
Except me.
Brent Halligan from the Scotland Yard.
Oh.
I think we're gonna do some mixing in there.
Not yet.
Oh.
Where did I come from?
A key.
Can I get this key?
It looks like it's guarded.
Oh.
I can't.
I don't know why, but I can't take anything from the altar.
Okay.
How do we know?
okay a door with a small lock how do we know what to put in what thing yeah there's a barrier how do I get out of here where did I come in from what's over here what's in here okay that's where I came from ah this is fire that won't help either fire fire hmm nothing's happening no uh what about this I'd rather think about it again okay the key with the fire symbol does not go into the fire lock
fireball the amulet oh good good thinking and think about that oh I completely the amulet what they kissed it's it's like a NFC tag or something okay now we light the both flints in here we start the fire wait can I combine I should think up something else yes yes yes burn baby burn Okay.
Why suddenly do I hear France?
Wait, what?
Did you guys hear that?
Why did I hear, why did I hear France all of a sudden?
Oh, this is earth.
Okay, we put the, we put the dirt in here.
Weep.
Weep, weep, weep.
Weep, weep.
It really looks like pot, like poo poo.
It's like it looks.
Do I...
I'd rather think about it again.
Okay, we just shut it, and it's fine.
Was that all I needed to do?
Hold on, I'm gonna double check.
Dirt in quotations.
Use the torch to open the grate underneath the orb.
What torch?
Weep.
I hear...
Uh, hold on.
Oh, and use the light to...
Okay, okay.
I did see that there was a torch in the previous room that was not lit up, and we're supposed to do that.
We're supposed to use the fire to light it up.
Okay, perfect.
Did we really have weeks of fun just to rip off the end of...
Don't say that!
I noticed this guy up here.
Aha!
Okay.
Nothing is ever not a coincidence in this game, I suppose.
What other music will play?
And the other ones, I wonder.
Bing.
Bing, Bing, Bing.
Was this the Earth?
Yes.
We're performing the ritual.
We're cooking the poo.
Okay.
Very nice.
To the next one.
I don't know why these doors exist if I can't just go in them.
Okay, this is...
This gotta be water, right?
The other one, and then the other one, the wispy one is the wind.
Aha!
That's not a lie.
I think maybe we should have gotten two ladles full.
The magic soup.
This is our love potion.
Okay!
Hooray!
Over here.
In here.
Yep.
We're just pump.
We're just going to put some air in there.
I hope it doesn't get out.
This is how magic air works, you guys.
Mouth to mouth.
Yippee!
Good thing it doesn't escape.
Yeah, good thing.
Goodness gracious.
Wait, we didn't get any other music for the video.
Hey.
Alright, I like that we just leave the door.
The door open.
They could be like, where does he, where could he be at?
Bum, bum, bum.
Okay, sorry, I'm saving again because I don't want to do...
I don't want to, like, repeat processes, you know what I mean?
Here we go!
Into the layer.
Is this where the babies are?
Oh my god.
He's in a big rush now.
He's like, pizza!
Pizza, pizza!
I gotta go on my pizza date!
Oh shoot, there's things I should be looking at.
A stone plate.
There's a symbol on it.
So you carried a ladle full of water in your pocket?
Okay, hold on.
I gotta go back up the stairs.
I wasn't paying attention.
No, no.
Okay.
I was so excited for pizza.
That was Earth.
I need some water soon.
Oh, maybe there's... Okay.
Those were the first two.
Okay, so Earth Fire.
I don't know if we have to remember the order for this but it was earth fire
hmm I am captain planet captain planet he's a hero gonna take pollution down to zero more
fire wait uh oh wait what what was the what was the one I just grabbed oh a stone plate there's a symbol on it can I put these back let me check that too okay I can not.
I can only take them.
I, yeah, I can only takeeth, I may not giveeth.
Are we going to be conducting like science down here?
Equations, perhaps?
I don't want to do equations.
Oh, wow, we do!
We have to do equations!
Did I miss some?
Heck.
Oh, sorry, my big head's blocking it, but it's the stick.
It won't work.
Something is preventing me from taking the staff okay
there has to be a way of knowing what i'm combining though right
like what's the clue
walkthrough so true
okay basically the walkthrough is just like okay we need to get eight plates one two three i have six i missed two plates we gotta go back It doesn't matter which one we do first, I gotta go back.
Is it over here?
Uh, other side?
Maid, mint, phantom.
That's me!
I'm mint phantom and I'm a maid.
Where were they?
Am I blind?
We need two more.
Where are they?
Top two?
Hmm?
Near the...
Near the top?
Of the whole staircase?
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Oh, I didn't see this one.
Obviously.
Ah!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Thank you, guys.
Pizza, pizza, pizza, pizza!
You think he's in the pits?
Armpits?
Sneaky, sneaky!
Ah, they were so sneaky.
Alright.
The guide basically is like...
The guide says I'm not explaining this puzzle.
Because the orientation is hard to grasp.
Here's some pictures.
So first we go into here.
Oh, what a thrill.
Ancient staircase addition.
Showing you the angle and the plates to use.
So this is the earth on the top.
I'm guessing this is what he means by top slot.
So earth and air.
how am i supposed to know this just trial and error like how the hell
oh sorry sorry you guys are so right i did okay what confused me okay you're right this is this is water yes thank you guys thank you so much what got me was um they drew like the zigzags the guide and that's i was like oh zigzaggies okay weeks weeks of fun okay next room is uh maybe this one and this is water on the top and air on the bottom.
What's the speed run for?
What's the time for this game?
Okay, next.
This one.
Thank you guys for letting me use the walkthrough.
I really appreciate it.
Air.
And water.
Obviously, you would magically know by doing the following consider your current situation is it like what they were paired with upstairs I don't think so I don't think these these they were paired like this on the stairs and last but not least this room which is fire
fire you just keep trying until you can try no holy cow oh my gosh imagine all the pieces of paper people just like Okay, I tried this one.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't even imagine how long this would take.
I can't.
Fire, fire.
Like the fire.
I can't even imagine how long this would take.
Let's hit 30, baby.
The big three-hole.
I just saw the rest of the walkthrough, and I'm very excited.
Yahoo!
What are you doing?
Melanie.
Brent.
Oh.
he's going to kill me let her go she hasn't got anything to do with this i came here on my own you have something that belongs to me give it to me now brent do what he says he's serious you heard what she said she's absolutely right brent please no when he has the staff he'll kill us both listen sir stan i'll give you the staff on one condition yeah you must swear that nothing will happen to either Melanie or me afterwards what that is your condition swear on your honor it doesn't mean anything to me whether you sad creatures live or die if you really want to hear it I swear it on your honor on my honor okay now let Melanie go oh my god give me the staff I'll put it down here as soon as you let her go come here Melanie come here Melanie what is he gonna do I now our face will be sealed the ritual may begin but first I will take care of you two oh my god you swore on your honor you miserable fools
Oh my god, we're fading!
He lied!
Wait, what happened to us?
Oh, we're back!
But we're gonna fall into the pit again.
Did we...
This is how Melanie came walking in.
Wait.
Rent?
Yes?
I'm still alive.
It would appear so.
Where?
Where are we?
Did they, maybe because...
Wait.
We must be back in our own time.
My god, the ritual.
We must get to Stonehenge immediately.
Sinclair is going to complete the ritual.
Come on, Melanie, we've got to try to stop him.
Why didn't we stop him back then?
What was the point of going back in time?
What was the point?
For fun.
We could have broken the little stick and then it would have been fine.
To get the mistletoe.
It has to be.
Oh!
St. Clair!
Mr. Halligan, have you come to witness our finest hour?
Very well, my friend.
are most welcome to come and watch yeah because he likes to do that i like to watch
nobody said the time has come let us begin oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
okay this is what i apparently have to do
Shias ruined I don't know how I would know to do this
Oh what
It's because he said no harm would come to them.
I guess he didn't say until when.
This could be forever.
Why is everybody frozen?
Wait!
The healing mistletoe!
It's not just regular mistletoe!
Remember, guys, it's healing mistletoe.
Oh my god, oh my god!
Have they gone now?
Yes, yes, they've gone.
Oh god, what a sight.
Everything will be okay.
Just lie still.
Brent...
Brent, am I going to die?
Nonsense.
You're going to be just fine.
That's what you told Malgoy too.
Just lie completely still.
I'll go and get help.
Don't go and get help!
Brent, it's cold here.
I'm so cold.
Oh no!
Melanie!
Use the healing mistletoe!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, you just put it on top?
Is that how that works?
Oh, it's magic.
Oh my god.
Not the way I thought we'd be using the mistletoe.
Melanie.
Brent.
What did you do?
I just practiced a bit of magic.
That's all.
Now we laugh together.
No.
Shh.
I
am milk.
I've been tears.
Who didn't die in this game?
Girl, he stabbed you.
Would that work on you?
I don't know.
I think it would be quite exciting to see, um, to see, uh, a druid cult die, uh, be evaporated, Thanos in front of my eyes.
So who knows?
You have to watch the mystery of the druids ending animation after the credits.
Okay.
There's an after credits?
Let's go.
The team wishes to thank all who supported us during the production, with patience and understanding, suggestions, and criticism, but also with warm meals and walks at Moonlight.
How romantic.
No wonder it was such a romantic ending.
Wow.
Oh, wow.
How's a piece of power?
Screams and Butler.
Oh, okay.
I see, I see.
Where's the explosions?
I guess we didn't.
We did.
Some endings don't go out with a bang.
Well, maybe they did.
The ending is...
The music is so quiet.
Al-Halligan could have sacrificed himself, but he had to be a psycho.
He has a lust for blood.
and in crimes.
He's like, I've gotten...
Oh my god.
He's like, I've gotten away with everything so far.
Can I get away with murder?
What a house of tales indeed.
What a story that was.
The Druid's ending animation is a fan production.
Oh, okay.
Oh, this is just...
Okay, this is just the opening of the game again.
Because there was no opening.
There was no title menu is what I meant to say.
Fan ending song.
What the hell are you guys telling me to look up here?
What am I looking up?
Mystery of the Druids.
Ending.
Is this gonna give me copyright strike?
Wait, which one is it?
I don't know.
Zillofenko?
Okay.
Give me one second.
Oh, now I get to watch the Mandalore game.
That's the video you guys were saying to watch, right?
After I beat the game was the Mandalore gaming?
It shouldn't?
Okay, cool.
Uh, let me do this.
One moment, please.
Oh, let me open the animation.
Oh, wait.
Oh, this works, actually.
Okay, give me a second.
Uh, window capture.
And, oh, oh, it already worked.
How handy duty is that?
Okay, and, uh, oh, and I...
and mystery of the druids oh hello how do I hello OBS OBS OBS I why can't I crop why can't I crop it hello that's strange maybe try a filter effect filter is is there a crop oh yeah there is a crop okay i'll just crop it myself okay no worries we figure out we we adapt we are strong we just we just fought off the druid so i think we're okay why obs did you make it so that i can't crop anymore also i'm in a private or like a you know what's the window private uh secret window so sorry if there's some weird like like recommended videos after,
you know?
Okay.
Let's watch.
Incognito, I don't know why, because it's called private browsing and Firefox.
I was like, what's the name again?
Okay, here we go.
Oh.
Oh,
my gosh.
They all have an attitude.
Skeleton eyes!
The truth are coming.
The truth are scary.
The Scotland Yard is getting wary.
But Alakins coming to solve the quarrel.
Don't
have an attitude.
It's the mystery of the truth.
This is so cute.
No
time for women.
I wish we could have gone on a beach vacation.
Yeah!
Cute.
Is that why everybody calls it druids?
Mystery of the druids?
Instead of druids?
And that's why they all have an attitude?
Yes.
Oh, I've learned!
I've learned!
Some characters in the game says druids.
Really?
I didn't hear.
I tried looking out for it.
speaking of deadly premonition actually that's on my list of things to play so probably maybe like next month spooky month right try princess thank you thank you thank you thank you what a journey this was hmm sure was something Halligan stayed true to himself and was an awful human being until the very end and he still got the girl girl i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna have nightmares about him like brushing her lips like that what
was that game i don't know oh yeah we did
it with me
gosh oh melanie raise your standards well how would she know i guess well she knows that okay those lips have touched human meat girl like and they have consumed this but she couldn't know everything else that he's done but actually she knows that he got fired she knows that do we get our job back what do we do now
man oh he also slapped and strangled her maybe that awoke in something in her were so strong.
Oh, and she saw all the pizza boxes.
It must have been a moment of weakness for her.
I can't imagine they stay together.
It was a moment of weakness.
It must have been.
Because there's just no way.
She's like, oh yeah, like later on they're going to be like, he's going to be like, so about that pizza date she's gonna be like oh sorry about that pizza date she's gonna be like oh that date we never found out what happened to the royal family
it was the blood loss yeah
wow did he ever find his wallet I bet Lowry took it probably well guys This was such a time.
This was the most time.
This was it.
Thank you so much.
Oh, man, I'm going to exit out of the game on my end.
Quit game.
Okay.
Oh, wow.
Thank you so much for Mystery of the Druids.
And I hope you guys have a great day.
have a great night have a great time zone sorry my voice is a little icky so i'm gonna go rest and tomorrow we start fatal frame yippee yippee a new fatal frame i've been avoiding all all spoilers so thanks for the playthrough silly game thank you thank you for the pink and yeah ultimate thank you everybody
whoa did i say fatal frame oh my god sorry i was just kidding Like, why do I keep doing this?
Sorry, I'm at Silent Hill.
I keep calling it Silent Hill Fatal Frame because, you know.
Oh, my brain is messed up.
My brain is messed up.
Silent Hill F is Fatal Frame.
Yeah.
I should play Fatal Frame at some point, though.
Hmm.
Okay, sorry.
Anyway, bye!